le devoir de mémoire un volet important
de la formation des cadets
d'ile-de-france jeudi 24 février lorenzo
bentata et mehdi aigles ont vécu avec
leurs camarades une journée spéciale dès
l'aube rendez-vous au carré des soldats
du cimetière municipal du chéné
aujourd'hui on est actuellement en train
de nettoyer les les tombes des anciens
soldats qui sont morts pour la france et
donc on a on a plusieurs manières de
nettoyer donc on utilise un produit pour
retirer pour retirer battue où toutes
les traces de noir et on frotte avec
avec une brosse et
et ensuite on est en train de
de repeindre en fait le nom des anciens
soldats et de pouvoir enfin permettre
que ça se voit mieux
[Musique]
c'est important c'est quand même des
soldats qui sont morts pour la frappe là
où je vis mon pays donc vraiment
important il faut le faire même si c'est
pas les
appliquer
la cohésion dire que tout seul ils sont
qui peuvent rien faire et c'est avec le
groupe qui sont plus forts ils sentent
qu'ils ont quelque chose à faire pour la
collectivité franchement ils sont très
volontaires on va on va changer de
tomber on va essayer d'attaquer
d'attaqué sur sur une nouvelle tombe ou
sinon de renforcer une équipe qui est
déjà sur une tournée on essayait de on
va essayer de les aider un peu là est
donc bon bah on va on va chercher le
matos et puis on va attaquer
après plus d'une heure de labeur le
groupe de mehdi et lorenzo réhabilite
leur troisième tombe de la matinée quand
soudain en a croisé une dame mais ça
donne nous disait que c'était la tombe
de son grand père qui est qui est tombé
pour la france aussi en 1900 1915 c'est
ça et elle était elle était très émue et
nous aussi on est assez mieux justement
d'apprendre cette nouvelle et
c'est quelque chose de bien et nous à
nous ça nous encourage encore plus parce
qu'on sait qu'il ya quand même des
familles derrière et et voilà c'est
important de les restaurer dans tous les
cas mon grand père a été tué en 1915 à
arras près d'arras et donc
[Musique]
chaque année j'essaye de d'entretenir sa
tombe de brosser etc et là je vois que
tous ces jeunes ont fait un geste très
touchant en essayant de récupérer la le
mauvais état de la pierre et je suis
très très ému vraiment à 11 heures
sonnent la fin de ce travail d'intérêt
général
le temps d'une pause pour déjeuner puis
les cadets se sont rendus au mont
valérien à suresnes au programme visites
et cérémonie d'hommage enfin alors que
la nuit tombe une dernière étape
parisienne la cérémonie du ravivage de
la flamme sous l'arc de triomphe
lorenzo a été choisi pour être l'un des
porte drapeaux
quant à mehdi il est chargé comme le
reste des cadets de déposer une rose au
pied de la tombe du soldat inconnu je
suis fier d'être issu de pouvoir être
ici on a une chance et je suis aussi
fier de pouvoir porter le drapeau est de
pouvoir être être sûr sur les
champs-elysées en plein paris c'est une
première expérience pour moi enfin pour
nous tout ceci je pense et c'est pas
tous les jours qu'on fait sentir fier en
plus avec le monde qui nous regardent de
tours à l'arc de triomphe
[Musique]
important pour leur faire comprendre
d'où ils viennent et voyez le en règle
générale je leur pose la question qui
est sous la tombe il me répond je sais
pas c'est un inconnu en cash moment là
je leur dit non j'ai pas l'inconnu c'est
un soldat français une cérémonie
habituelle presque quotidiennes au pied
du grand édifice qui restera pourtant
singulière est gravé dans la mémoire des
jeunes cadets le terme d'une journée
chargée d'émotion
[Musique]
à
or
e